[Musique]
donnez les mots vous pouvez vous passer
de votre téléphone pour quelques heures
et si je vous disais une histoire plutôt
de héros de méchants d'aventuré et de
magie rêve de voir de la vraie magie
derrière les murs de ce manoir il y a
des secrets bien cachés
j'ai vu un truc là-bas
[Musique]
tu ne risques rien et tu viens d'où
exactement un monde magique
malheureusement tout cela a disparu
notre reine nous a envoyé ici pour
sauver notre monde et empêcher son
extinction mais bien sûr une sorcière
maléfique nous à suivre je ne vois pas
que je sais de sauver notre monde notre
monde ne vaut pas la peine d'être
des magiciens des portail magique lilith
une sorcière qui est prêt à assommer
d'autres vous attendez quoi on y va ou
fatwa ouvrait toutes les plantes on a
besoin que de quatre éléments
je lai
découvrez de nouveaux mondes et
condé à l'appel
vraiment tu sors un poignard à une
bataille de sorcier elle n'a pas tort on
est tous derrière toi
plus fusée le royaume d'aline à voir so
lu ment